for those with loved ones in long-term
care the weight has been agonizing for
more than ten weeks they've been unable
to visit in person unable to hug or even
hold the hand of the person they love
staying away is supposed to stop the
spread of kovat 19:00 but we know it has
already spread like wildfire in hundreds
of homes it's so bad the military has
been called in no one ever thought
soldiers would be looking after its
seniors yet there they are 1,400 troops
deployed in 25 long-term care homes in
Quebec and 275 working in five
facilities in Ontario how did it come to
this Mike Armstrong takes us through it
even before there was a request for help
the Canadian Armed Forces were preparing
planning for what might come in a normal
spring it's usually flooding or forest
fires but by this meeting April 6th
there was also the increasing likelihood
troops would be needed in a fight
against kovat 19
the coronavirus was already sweeping
through seniors residences in Quebec and
Ontario the death toll was rising what
it was also doing was exposing the
fragility of the system even before
kovat nineteen quebec's long term care
facilities were already struggling with
staffing this took them past the
breaking point
some residents has lost more than half
their staff to infection to preventive
leave or even out of fear
a desperate Premier called on anyone in
the healthcare system to help out we
need you to do the basic work I appeal
to your sense of duty to help us take
care of the elderly those appeals went
out daily and didn't work there were
more and more stories about overworked
staff being overwhelmed Canadian doctors
who volunteer in other countries on
humanitarian missions were told by
Quebec's health minister to stay home
what I'm saying is that this year now I
think the humanitarian mission is here
in Quebec in our long-term facilities
the first call to the military for help
was April 15th
there was a Wednesday by the Saturday
troops wrote on recce visiting
residences to see what was needed and
where they were very welcome people were
clapping listen this situation is so
dire that people need help
by that Monday April 20th about 65
troops moved into five Quebec residences
that first phase was soldiers with
medical backgrounds physicians nurses
orderlies and they were able to jump
right into the action all we barely got
in and we were already working knees
even in we were we were put to work as
fast as they could
now despite that initial response
staffing shortages turned into a
full-blown crisis there were cases where
residences saw their entire staff not
show up for work it reached the point
where kovat 19 wasn't the only thing
sending seniors to hospital it was also
inadequate care there were cases of
dehydration and malnutrition April 22nd
the premier put out another call the
station and senior residences is still
critical
today we've hashed the federal
government to send a thousand soldier
the second wave of soldiers was more
complicated to deploy they needed
training and how to use protective gear
and some of the basics and how to care
for seniors the tasks were similar to
what an orderly might do and very
different from what most troops signed
up for once on the ground they knew they
were needed it's a lot of work but it's
a good work that we're doing it's a
we're taking a lot of the stress out of
the civilian employees that are working
there full-time the troops have been
called extra arms even if they don't
have the medical background staff would
normally have they're helping how much
when we put that question to this nurse
recently she answered with exasperation
I can't point I can't point now Cyndi
hubby show says the soldiers have let
her and the rest of the staff breathe
and made them feel supported
she also said they're already nervous
about what happens when the soldiers
leave
operation laser is the name of Canada's
military response to this pandemic and
colonel tim arsenault is the commander
of it in long-term care homes in the
montreal area he's leading the teams of
reservists and Regular Force members who
are not only from Quebec but from all
over Canada colonel arsenal thank you so
much for joining us you served in Bosnia
and in Afghanistan and in Ukraine you're
an infantry officer now you're helping
in a war against a virus inside Care
Homes in Canada this isn't what anyone
in the military signed up for what's
been the greatest challenge it is a
significant challenge to operate in a
pandemic environment especially at home
I think a year ago none of us would have
expected that we'd be involved in a
mission of this nature however you know
that our business is adapting to
challenging environments and our
soldiers have definitely shown that that
we're very capable of adapting to this
one as well give me a sense of the
logistics we know that one of the main
reasons care homes are so badly infected
with covin 19 is because staff prior to
this we're moving from care home to care
home and working in multiple facilities
so how are you ensuring that there isn't
the kind of cross infection and that you
know enough care is taken that that both
your soldiers and people inside that
care homes are not going to get covert
90 as you know we're used to deploying
and large numbers occupying caps large
groups of soldiers living together
traveling together working together this
situation is very different and that we
need to make sure that we don't become
vectors of the virus within the the
homes I've you've as you've pointed out
that entails a lot of changes in terms
of transportation feeding plans bed down
in terms of you know having each soldier
needs to have their own room with their
own with their own their own washroom to
ensure that that we don't pass it off to
each other and then then again into the
homes and in terms
you know the cross-pollination between
centers we're applying the same rules as
as the ministry is so our teams in
general terms are not moving from one
facility to the next and those specific
medical teams that are more of a limited
resource when we do need to to move them
it's done in accordance with provincial
regulations in that regard
how many soldiers have tested positive
for covin 19 and have any become
seriously ill I'm not at liberty to
speak of the specifics of the numbers as
they are today
or I can't tell you that the numbers
will increase the numbers are very small
given the number of troops that we have
working in long-term care facilities
everyone very much appreciates
everything that you're doing but as the
prime minister said soldiers really
shouldn't be taking care of seniors his
operational laser kind of an indefinite
operation at this point you'll note that
since since the the end of April we we
initially provided support to five
long-term care facilities we sharply
increased that over the course of the
first few weeks have made 225 centres
within the Montreal region again over a
thousand soldiers directly involved in
the long-term care facilities we have
around 1,400 soldiers in the Montreal
region tat in total including the
logistics and and in command and control
elements so we're here to provide that
assistance for as long as the government
asks us to do so